[Musique]
vous avez le sentiment donc que la
négritude un concept plus radical plus
radical et plus large et plus généreux
et plus généreux et qui comporte
qui souligne une fidélité et un devoir
de mémoire combien d'Antillais j'ai
connu en France quand je suis arrivé qui
avait honte de se dire antillais
martiniquais ou guadeloupé combien
d'entre eux avaient encore honte de
l'Afrique et qui se disait sud-américain
oui ils étaient prêts à être créés pas
du tout la qualité africaine non et bien
c'est pas que cet aspect
de l'héritage parce que négliger parce
que avili parce que déprécié c'est
celui-là que j'ai revendiqué et c'est
pour cela
s'il n'avait autrement je vais faire
autre chose mais il y avait ça et il
fallait il fallait rétablir une vérité
historique ils connaissait plus rien
d'Afrique c'est incroyable alors que
qu'est-ce que conseil
une confirmation tout ce malaise que je
ressentais confusément de ma société
martiniquaise dans les salons parmi mes
camarades au lycée et où il y avait tant
de bêtises de blanc pas du tout compte
pas du tout contre ça va être que je
ressentais
je ne sais pas très bien la cause
et puis avec ce gorge j'ai compris ce
qu'en réalité j'appelle confusément
compris et senti comme peuvent le faire
les enfants que nous étions de ce monde
de fausses valeurs et elle était fausse
et tout simplement nous avons hérité des
valeurs qu'avait inventé été inventé à
l'usage des colonies par la classe
dominante mais pas autre chose c'est ça
qui est vrai et alors moi ma révolution
précisément ça a été de faire l'inverse
et c'est parce que il y avait un élément
qui est à mon avis capitale
un élément fondamental
un élément
et qui était négligé
et rejeter et discréditer
c'est pour cela que je vous mette
l'accent là dessus d'autant plus que je
le savais et que je le sentais
et capital en France c'était m'inscrit
au lycée Louis le Grand avec une belle
lettre de mon professeur de géographique
normaux
d'Alençon c'est normal
et qui avait remarqué certaines copies
qui étaient de moi intéressant original
et puis
il me dit un jour alors
sa grande barbe de curé
comme vous
c'est le professeur
comme moi ce que tu vas faire tu iras en
France et tu vas préparer l'École
normale elle dit qu'est-ce que c'est
l'école normale il m'a fait un topo
il m'a appelé vous allez partir en
France
un petit mot pour un homme qui avait été
le faire promotion monsieur abri
l'auteur de Manuel a brûlé grouzé que
vos grands-pères ont dû connaître bon et
bien c'était professeur il était
professionnel
du lycée un pas de lycée du secrétariat
se rend compte là sous le balcon un
petit homme noir avec une grande blouse
grise avec la taille entourée d'une
ficelle au bout de laquelle en crier et
tout de suite reconnu les habitués de la
maison tout le monde dit il est interne
c'était la grande coquetterie à cette
époque là il y avait un mois la souriant
il me dit dis-donc bisous d'où viens-tu
quel est ton nom
rappelle mes Césaire et je suis de la
Martinique moi je suis Léopold Sédar
saga et du Sénégalais il me prononc dans
ses bras et bien désormais tu seras mon
bijou voilà comment la rencontre s'est
faite et bien pendant longtemps donc
j'ai vécu axenghor beaucoup de
martiniquais mais le reprochait bah il
voit pas du tout que c'est et toujours
avec des Africains etc c'était un peu
vrai
beaucoup de choses
ça c'est touchant de vieillards
je me fais aperçu que j'avais
l'impression qu'on continue à la
conversation qu'on avait commencé plus
de 60 euros 70 ans plus tôt
a eu le grand à l'École normale et alors
Senghor m'a appris une chose il m'a
appris l'Afrique
la grandeur de l'Afrique la noblesse
culturelle et l'Afrique moi ce qui m'a
appris et qui est important et en me
révélant en Afrique je me suis rendu
compte qui me révélait en même temps à
moi-même et qui me révélait la
Martinique parce que la partie qui est
une société
que les clés et les attendus sont
ailleurs et ils sont en Afrique c'est ça
que j'ai compris très tôt
sans miel
mais des choses fondamentales comment
comprendre la musique Martinique comment
comprendre le folklore martiniquais
comment comprendre le créole lui-même si
on ne tient pas compte cet élément
africain c'est évident pas plus qu'on ne
peut comprendre le français
[Musique]